(617) 830-4750 is the number.
Let's go next.
Well let's just check in with Dante from Florida
who I want to get it right.
Dante.
Cause every time you correct me, you're a
Bernie guy but you like Tulsi, is that correct?
[inaudible]
yes, I'm a Bernie Sanders supporter and I
wouldn't affect goes together when she's correct.
Got it.
Okay good.
What's going on?
So the question I had was, so there are a
lot of from the left wing intellectuals like
dr Cornell West and Noam Chomsky, they make
the point that you can't really have a left
wing movement without a real criticism of
us foreign policy.
So my question is for all people who consider
themselves progressive and leftist and non
intervention is, shouldn't Elizabeth Warren's
foreign policy be a disqualifying factor for
what which uh, which position of her specifically
though?
Do you mean?
I mean her Mo, a lot of her positions on foreign
policy, I just bad.
She's not really, she hasn't really had a
well on the Israel Palestine conflict back
in, I think it was like 2014, 2015 something
like that when Yahoo was doing the massacre
and God's in the West bank.
She was literally using a, um, idea of talking
points about human shields and they have to
defend themselves and all of that.
Um, on other issues like Yemen, she hadn't
really been out front and it's important that
and voting on the military budget, but it's
important that, especially in the time that
we are now, we're in eight illegal Wars, the
illegal war in Iraq.
Yeah, man.
Furio it's important that we have somebody
who's out front on these issues of foreign
policy and whether the deployment is definitely
not going to do that.
She, she usually goes along with whatever
the establishment wisdom is in the national
security apparatus and she lives with the
generals.
And if you're going to do that into the white
house, it's just going to be a continuation
of the disastrous, he was foreign policy.
So let's see if we can dis-aggregate some
of those things.
I mean, uh, so the, her vote on military spending
is the one thing that you've mentioned that
is the most concerning to me.
Uh, and I'm, I'm absolutely on board as far
as that goes.
You know, her line about Israel has to be
allowed to defend itself.
Bernie Sanders literally used that same line
during his 2016 campaign and an angered a
lot of people on the left.
Um, but that is not, uh, that, that line,
you know, Bernie used that line as well.
And that is not really a concern to me.
What's more of a concern to me is what is
going to be the relationship between the American
president and the sometimes right-wing governments
of Israel in terms of looking other the other
way when it comes to things like settlements
for example, or what have you.
So I don't think that that line from Elizabeth
Warren from five years ago is particularly
problematic.
Now, as you mentioned, I think that Elizabeth
Warren will just listen to the generals.
I believe that basically everybody who has
a shot at this thing on the democratic side
is going to listen to the generals and I don't
think that that's a bad thing in a sense.
I mentioned last week, a lot of people write
into me Dante and they say, David, aren't
you worried that Bernie will weaken our military?
Aren't you worried that Warren will weaken
our military, that they won't do anything
if we're attacked?
I think that Biden, Warren and Bernie, who
are the three people at this point who have
a shot all recognize unlike Donald Trump,
that they are not the experts about when and
how to use the military and they are going
to listen to their generals and the Pentagon.
I don't think that that's different with the
three of them.
What is different is from it from a geopolitical
perspective, their outlook on some of these
conflicts and issues, but I think when it
comes down to the issues of national security,
I think they're all gonna listen to the generals.
Yeah.
I listened in logistically like, okay, if
when you've moved through like Bernie Sanders,
he said if he wants to end the war, so he
wants to get our troops out of Iraq, Afghanistan,
Syria and all these other conflicts.
So he's not, he's not going to be deferring
to the general
hello.
All right, we lost Dante.
Okay.
It's weird.
I thought it sounded like there was a kid
screaming or a cat screeching.
Um, and then we suddenly lost him, which was
very, very strange.
Let's go to a quick break and then we'll come
back and do more calls right after this, uh,
unclear what it is that happened with the
phone system there, but we will figure it
out and then be right back